[Music]
despite the turbulent bitter fight
surrounding his nomination my urban hope
is that Brett Kavanaugh will work to
lessen the divisions in the Supreme
Court so that we have far fewer 5-4
decisions and so that public confidence
in our judiciary and our highest court
is restored more senator Susan Collins
criticizing the partisanship throughout
the Cavanaugh confirmation hearing her
hope that justice Cavanaugh will help
restore confidence in our system here
with more reaction to today's major
breaking news senator Ted Cruz of Texas
senator I know in 32 days you're on the
ballot yeah you're going up against
what's a beta O'Rourke whose parent lead
become a I keep reading a cult figure in
spite of some pretty awful things he's
written about women a and apparently
according to a police report he got a
DUI and lied about leaving the scene of
an accident according to the report but
how would he vote in the Senate would he
vote for Senator Schumer would he have
voted against judge Kavanagh bet
O'Rourke is a hard no on Brett Kavanaugh
he was a hard no before these
allegations he's a hard no afterwards
he's running a hard left campaign like
like Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth Warren
and and I think this Kavanagh fight
really underscores what the stakes are
in US Senate races across the country
today was a very good day tomorrow
judge Brett Kavanaugh is going to become
justice Brett Kavanaugh but we won by
the slimmest of margins and it's why
this election matters it's why it
matters that we come out and stand up
because the smear campaign we have seen
particularly in the last two weeks has
been a new and disgraceful low for the
United States Senate and and and it's
not acceptable to just go after and and
and and slander judge Cavanaugh slanders
family treat his kids to this kind of
horrific abuse it's not right you know
senator I've lived
New York rough-and-tumble of New York
probably a little more streetwise than I
should be in life but I but I'd rather
live in Texas because you paid no state
income taxes in New York State and we'd
love to have you in Texas shot well I I
just want to ask this a look you've been
in rough in trouble races yeah you and
the president of disagreements but you
have supported the agenda of the biggest
tax cut security on borders conservative
originalist on the Supreme Court you are
known for your knowledge of the
Constitution what do you make of the
dangers if this behavior were to be
rewarded well what we've seen in the
last two years is the extreme left is
just filled with rage they're filled
with anger they're filled with hatred
for President Trump and it's spilling
out it's spilling out in in nasty and
angry protests during the Cavanaugh
hearings the first day of the hearing 70
people were arrested with the active
complicity of Democratic senators just
just yesterday 300 people were arrested
at the Capitol and we're seeing this
anger this bitterness you know this week
what we had someone send white powder to
our campaign office in Texas that ended
up having hazmat and the FBI called in
because the concern was that it was
anthrax or something it turned out to be
negative but we're in this environment
where there's an anger a rage of fury
and it's wrong it is wrong to just smear
someone's character like they've done to
judge Cavanaugh and for that matter it's
wrong to do what the Democrats did out
dr. Ford she asked that that are
allegations be kept confidential and and
the congressional Democrats apparently
didn't care and they outed her against
her will that that is wrong and we've
got to find a way to disagree with each
other but still engage with civility
treat each other with decency like human
beings you know look you were in a very
tough primary with President Trump it's
not beanbag you gave her you took and
you said at a debate recently that at
the end of the day you were asked well
why did you make the decision to go
along with the president and you said
because I'm here to represent the people
of Texas it's see
like that campaign and I know the
presidents are disrupter I know that he
breaks a lot of dishes but we see the
results now don't we and you put the
people of your state ahead
it's nothing ever has been this bad I've
never seen things as awful now the the
anger the fury the the the frankly
threats of violence are really
disturbing due process who people are
showing up at their house who are
threatening their family I mean it's not
good for this country and and you know
you look at this hearing I mean the the
basic principles of due processes you
said the basic principles of the
presumption of innocent that you're
innocent until proven guilty you know
listen once these allegations were made
they were serious they needed to be
treated with respect we needed to have a
full and fair hearing and we did we
needed to give dr. Ford an opportunity
to tell her story and treat her with
respect and we did but we Cavanaugh an
opportunity to defend himself and he
should have been treated with respect
and he wasn't the Democrats couldn't
instead that they did theatrics and mock
outrage they were shocked shocked that
they're actually teenagers drink in high
school and college goodness gracious and
they were even more shocked that
seventeen-year-old say stupid things in
their yearbooks I mean it was a
ridiculous circus and and they were
willing to smear a good man and his
family simply for political ends that
that's not a mere operation that's
exactly right there was no collaboration
yes hey I asked you this I watched you
and I know your wife Heidi I watched you
get running out of a restaurant I we've
seen it happen to Secretary Nielsen Pam
Bondi it's happened to Sarah Sanders
Mitch McConnell you happening like on a
daily basis I don't think you should
leave the halls of the Senate open yeah
and I'm saying that for the safety the
protective protection of people we elect
I I fear for everyone's safety at this
moment there are a lot of senators who
are having that conversation you know
Monday night Heidi was up in DC and the
two of us went out about 9 o'clock at
night to do a date night just the two of
us we don't get to do that very often we
showed up at a restaurant that we love
it's a delightful restaurant
unfortunately somehow the protestors
were there waiting for us as we walked
in
surrounded us they screamed at us that
they basically shut down the restaurant
and they made it impossible to have
dinner and and so Heidi and I got up to
leave they blocked her from getting out
when we left the restaurant you know
this actually has not been reported but
we left the restaurant we went out the
door and around a back alley and this
mob of about 15 screaming leftist
protesters chased Heidi and me down the
alley screaming and yelling at us a
waiter from the restaurant led us in the
back door to the kitchen and we took
shelter in the kitchen with this
screaming mob outside now I'll tell you
a happy ending to that so about ten
minutes later the police arrived and
they removed the protesters and I asked
Heidi I said okay well what do you want
to do now do you want to go somewhere
else what do you want to know she said
no I like this restaurant let's go have
date night so we went back through the
kitchen sat down at the same table and
we had a delightful romantic dinner just
the two of us good ending to the story
centered a voice stood up for the
Constitution these deeply held
principles of due process and
presumption of innocence and your
election is important in 32 days we wish
you all the best thanks for being with
us thank you Shawn and everyone come to
Ted Cruz org stand with us we're
fighting for the country